they should be live I don't have the
chat open but I'll open up the chat and
I'm not wasting any time I just started
a game against evolution ruse hopefully
easier stoper 10 seconds to move nathan
is here and Ariel is here hello guys
four three two
oh so sad
maybe fell asleep around away well I
have a challenge from big girl
so we'll accept him hello Africa
I think today will be only games ten
minutes or longer just because I want a
slower pace want time to think and not
flag let's play a Sicilian
quest perk or modern what's modern Tiger
well here we have a Smith Mora which is
actually a fun opening to play against
I like to accept the gambit and just be
up upon
he's taking some time here is he
considering treating this as a Danish
I should respond to him in the chat
hello night f3
um I mean I could take on b2 and be up
two pawns
that's what Yasser would do
but I have cool preparation against
mainline Smith Morra so I kind of just
want to transpose
they'll play e6 and just let him take
when he wants to
Ioan Chadha thanks for the host I think
that was an auto host yeah that wasn't
auto host thank you anyway
I don't know if you're around though
Bishop e2 was that sound Nathan with the
host thanks Nathan well now I'm really
tempted to just win another pawn
could it get if I take and Bishop take
and then I play something like not have
six he has he 595
if you like when his Bishop is on b2 he
doesn't want his pawn on e5 so I don't
think I should be scared of this
hello to more people in the chat hello
chess trainee hello to Phoenix live full
of charm our low piano gioco thanks for
comment
low Aeneas
um so life is good right now I'm up to
pawns but white is up more open files
and he plays d5 but he kicks a knife but
kind of close us down this Bishop 95 is
most natural I could throw in Bishop
before check if Queen a5 I want
Bishop b4 check
ninety-two and then I can consider 94 as
well
let's start with this
at least make him choose between these
two moves or this move
King f1 okay looks very sketchy now 95
probably makes the most sense because 94
it's just unstable probably runs into
Queen d4
usually when you gambit to pawns you
want initiative you want your pieces to
be good if this bishop isn't impressive
this Bishop isn't impressive and now
this bishop is slightly more impressive
he wants to maybe take on d5 the great
thing about being up to pawns is that if
I lose upon I'm still up upon
so I might consider sacking just a
complete development
so castling is a candidate move Knight
b6 of course as a candidate move Queen
b6 you can see 785
choices choices
93 looks like a juicy square but covered
by the f pong
Queeny five looks very reasonable
I run into a three just wanted to spend
the night
okay Queen a5 a3 Bishop e7 looks solid
yeah let's play queen 85
I don't see anything wrong with this if
he wants to take I'll take with Queen
and try and trade Queens yeah bye slow I
mean rapid or longer so yeah 10 minutes
or longer I guess is slower compared to
blitz or bullets so he plays a three
I'll play Bishop e7
the Bishop's a good defender still have
to develop these pieces will probably
look to play b6 bishop a6 if I can
it's not entirely clear like how he
develops this night when restricting
night c3 and he doesn't want to trade
I'm up to pawns hello elastic hold
Junior
have to get used to saying Junior
deepak is playing a second feed a
tournament next week in a foreign
country nice well good luck
if its next week there's only so much
preparation you can do in a week it's
sleep and exercise are probably the two
most important things and diets three
most important things
so he plays mighty - you might want to
play Knight P 3 which means can i still
play this Knight B 3 Queen 84
looks a little bit sketchy
also just play 96
you
it's still night b3
you
problem is when he plays Knight b3 it
kicks Mike
away from defending t5
so I want to be a little bit careful
we just castle
Sako pawn on d5
can also consider night b6
that looks wrong
[Music]
who maybe be 5v5 have any merit
ninety-three Queen b6 egg take take
Bishop e7 and end thanks to whoever did
something thanks Nathan
so okay b5 forcing move might be three
or he can take first and none Knight B 3
and then Queen b6 he takes I played
Bishop b7 I'm up upon LightSquared
Bishop is a monster let's go for this
yeah I'm completely okay sucking upon to
get initiative because I'll have
initiative I'll still beat up upon
Deepak
yeah Queen b6 or queen a for Queen b6
they have to make sure b7 is defended
after I take take yeah I want I want
Bishop e7
also a benefit of the pawn taking here
is now the six rink is open so my quick
my queen could swing over in some cases
and it was very possible after take
Bishop e7 I'll love to play queen g6
and just
just try and create some a king-sized
attack against the g2 pond
ona's buzzing ooh invited to a chess
tournament to check that out either
yeah there's a brick wall behind me
feels more rustic but I'm in the same
location where I screamed yesterday I
just changed to the other side of the
table this to have the rustic feeling
um Nathan with a hundred bits away it's
my move let's not get distracted
you plays Bishop DeForest so he's trying
to keep initiative and get some
positional compensation queen g6 looks
attractive though
because I don't think Mike Wheaton can
be the Serb on g6 he doesn't have a
LightSquared bishop and now I still want
to complete development maybe I'll put
my bishop on a6 or play a5 Bishop a6 in
some cases
and even you realize he could he had
some idea of a six I'll start with
ninety-six
if you six in that position
you six probably not because I just take
and Richie eight and yeah that would be
nice
so he plays Bishop c5
I don't have to take it could take it I
could castle
looking up
be seven Queens 85-95
and the night let's start with Bishop
b7
there's no increment so I do have to
manage time not get too distracted but
to answer Nathan's question I'm in st.
Louis
I'm in a house uh yeah
since in the US
he takes on d5 so 95 where it says queen
gonna go
to d1
take-take-take
I'm okay with trades
in quindi one saw me move
and then we're just going to trade
everything
you
I'm gonna still
deserve my LightSquared bishop
our n I think means right now but I
might be mistaken
okay I take he takes trade well he could
take on e7 but then I take on c1
yeah let's do it
trade more
I'll just put the bishop on c6
wait a minute can I take on f3 if Queens
egg f3 Queen B 1 you could play GTA f3
these rook g1 okay I'll play Bishop c6
he is 94
well I have the trick I'm in the castle
there's no reason to defend a pawn
please take the fun
you might be watching maybe I shouldn't
tell him what to do
you
okay I'm up upon still it's a nice
position this rook is stuck I don't
think he can activate it anytime soon
unless he wants to play King you too
this Bishop is such a monster his knight
is pinned messy Marvin is seem to take
the pawn you can take the pawn with the
rook or the Queen
tough decision
the plan for black is just like he plays
kingi - so he heard me maybe
I take on g2
I'd also have Queenie forecheck
in Queen III we trade
take
I think I can just take care
I'm up two pawns again this is attacked
this is attacked twice it's defended
twice now I just want to trade
everything
this pawn is going to be a long-term
weakness imagining some line oh and you
can't play rook g1 because I take with
the bishop on f3 because he could play
real cure
should not have said that but now I can
go back the night is still pinned
you can still take this fun
before is a nice move because I pin the
night I defend and maybe now I have
ideas of
some Czech
anytime I can take a nap three
you
Moochie future thanks for the follow
okay so he plays this move
Bishop c6 defending everything
trapping the rook now his rook has stuck
his knight is pinned
all of these things are defended rookie
one is coming very soon a rookie 8 maybe
rook 88 extra solid or maybe a 5 a 4
then rockets
plays rook d3
la 5
I'm in no rush
oh maybe now I'm in a rush because he
unpinned himself
you can play this move
I just want to win this pawn can be up
three pawns
if I can win the pawn and the file opens
and his king will be
getting mated am i following the speed
chess championship I watched a few
matches
I watched the I watched part of the
Hobby thawne Nakamura match i watch part
of the leslie so match i haven't been
following like the brackets too closely
I can't get distracted let's play b4
attack the Queen the queen is currently
defending this and this both of these
are attacked
I think I'm winning something here
okay winning the night
-
and probably the king
you
you
I guess I have to win more stuff for I
can win the king
today is MV Alvarez Dominguez oh wow is
Dominguez playing in st. Louis I feel
like he is he got a wild card and to
either sink felt caught for the Blitz in
the rapid tournament
what to do this is a pretty aesthetic
move right that's a nice move it's going
behind taking advantage of the pin chess
coach net
thanks for all the emotes
those are nice emotes um he just
resigned okay that scared me because the
game just he took on that seven the game
ended I thought like there's some kind
of weird checkmate
but okay good game thing yarol I think
he just sacked too many pawns which is
unfortunate for whites
yeah sometimes in life you have to take
what's free just hold on to it
accept a challenge make it random
give me a random number between one and
seven seven my chess rook Oh HS okay
wonder if u s-- related to HS net good
luck let's play efore
so for people who are challenging me I
see a lot of casual challenges but if
you want to make it rated that's
completely fine with me
um okay we'll play against up here it's
someone was recommending earlier that I
play the Pirates but now I'm playing
against it
I could actually transpose into like if
he plays g6 I could play what
transpire is in the London against Kings
Indian I could play Bishop at four let's
do this because it leads to a fun attack
Queen d2 and then Bishop h6
who did this against Carlson and just
got crushed I think MVL played this line
against Carlson in Beal and just
I'll plead
um it's usually a fun line for light if
you're not playing against Carlson so
ninety-seven signifies he probably wants
to play this move
so I actually forget do I play Bishop h6
immediately Bishop h6 immediately is
decent
sometimes 903 is good hello to the ice
um many things are new and Berenbaum
grips thanks for the thanks for the sub
wait a minute I feel like I've played
this line before against
I have a distinct memory answers
this is black against stockfish and just
getting crushed I'm pretty sure
stockfish played ePHI but I forget if he
took first I think you took first
and then II five
I have a feeling this is trouble for
black
I could be wrong
but
because uh
for a vision on the d-file the fact that
after take take the knight is pinned
and then
hey it's a cheer Nathan wants H for um H
where it's not necessarily a bad move
but
I think I have a better move here I
think there's some
some line where I just win material like
I can take this pawn
I'll play h4 if I get the chance if he
doesn't resign before then
so now if he takes on d4 I can I guess I
can take with check
and then I take on e7 I went upon
so I guess he's debating between this
and this
at least Nathan didn't say g4 like g4
makes no sense
and
remember is like some position where
that Ponzi on you game or something but
h4 makes a ton of sense in this sort of
structure where what it wants to play h5
and then
100 bits for g4s oh well what's funny
about this position is that a common
sequence is h4 h5 and men g4 just to
break through so that's that's very
possible but the focus here is in the
center
hello 2x I sparks and he's thinking so I
can't I can't do anything when he's
thinking um this is not as a new stream
location I'm at the same table I'm just
on the other side where I thought the
lighting is better and with the wall
behind me there won't be any background
noise
okay so now I can reveal that there is
actually a trap that if you took with
the night I would take here here oops
I can't dry rose you're here you're and
then queen defy would win the night and
that's how I lost a sock fish makes
several months ago but he takes with the
pawn
um
[Music]
okay I'm considering h4 I'll just play
it I know if it's the best move in the
position
that's I was
100 bits to bribe me to play a move and
the great thing is that okay I'm
threatening h5 and if he plays h5
himself I will play g4 that's a given
just pawn storm
in the position so sad for black like
look at his pieces
make them read they're embarrassed
I hate my that's six can i still play g4
here it makes some sense because I want
to play h5 if he takes I play h5 I can
also play h5 Knight take and then g4
what do i do first
g4 take h5
each five actually seems stronger
but I don't think there is any reason to
prepare h5
I just want to open the file immediately
100 bits for Queen h6 check Queen age 6
will come just not immediately after a
to wait for the rook to support h6 or I
can just currently the threat is to take
in men Queen h6 so
as my mouse DPI too high what does that
even mean I know dpi means dots per inch
but it's too high so it's too whoa
this is a big cursor again
I'm not gonna pre move in a slow game
especially I'm not gonna pre move
something that's not forced
fried liver attack
mmm probably at some point
I mean I was taught from a pretty early
age to play d3 rather than Knight g5 in
this fried liver variation so I probably
played against the fried liver more
frequently
but it's a playable opening I think that
blacks prepared it's not it's not too
dangerous but it's it's very sharp
that's interesting
so the higher dpi the faster the pointer
speed so that's a good thing I guess
bad thing
I seem to break the rule of developing
all my pieces
well I've developed the pieces that
matter
I guess these pieces haven't been
developed but in this variation
specifically white can sometimes just
afford to go for the immediate pond
lunge without developing these minor
pieces
I'm getting a media initiative and black
is also underdeveloped so like if you
can get the initiative while your
opponent is underdeveloped and good
things can happen so I'm going to take
and I still can't pre move queen h6
because he could be
he could snipe me and play like h5 but
now okay Queen h6 looks very attractive
now this is a case where my bishop might
yeah my bishop will now develop with
tempo
and sometimes you hold off development
because you're not sure how your pieces
should develop like a few moves ago
Bishop c4 it would not have made too
much sense but now it makes a ton of
sense
and now the question is becoming how do
I made him as quickly as possible
because his King has no squares I'm
envisioning my knight coming to g6 with
mates
or if I can remove this night Queens egg
f8 could lead to mates I could take on
g6 here
hmm I could also just go after each
seven just night at 3:03 looks nice
only ten for doing it late what did i do
late Quinn age six there's so many
mating ideas between 9h four and night
g6 and also Knight g5 in Queen take h7
I like Knight g5
it will enable the Queen sack
oh I forgot to play g4g 4 wasn't
necessary though
hopefully you was it that asked that
question
whereas the developing question Oh piano
gioco hopefully piano Chioggia is happy
but now I've developed my pieces like I
got the attack and now I develop my
pieces but he's defending so
seven
g6
options here
I mean I could play something like 95
even 94
I'll go for 94
because then I'll be sacking a night and
then a queen
if he wants to take
and the philosophy here is I just want
to attack with as many pieces as
possible like both nights Bishop the
Queen that rook they're all having some
influence in the position
and it's funny but the majority of
blacks pieces are on the queenside and
not helping defend the king so this is a
great sign in chess when you have more
pieces on the side of your opponent's
king and your opponent has on the side
of their king
late two nights against you says elastic
hold if I end up playing you then yes
but Siri is determining the fates of
everything d5 b5 is a good move kind of
forgot about that he opens up the Queen
can I get away with taking
right now
you
I mean I could just take on you'll just
take on f6 and then take on d5
not what I wanted though but that should
be good enough
you
oh he takes with night does it meet
somehow
where this has to be made somehow queen
f 898
maybe it's not meat
with Queen aphids
he has to play 98
me neither seven
it's a cheer from Nathan five hundred
bits new badge
Nathan just broke 5,000 weight ones
Nathan broke 5,000 bits like total
lifetime
I don't know what
mean by new badge
and jacksie sharing something from
divots key oh he broke ten gay
congratulations Nathan now I see the new
badge
and think you need and amaya point
resigned while some need good that good
things happening in one moment
um
rule well uh anything to talk about in
that game
yeah this position I'm pretty sure I've
had before against stockfish I don't
know if it will be in the opening
Explorer
take
you
so I remember very distinctly playing
against stockfish level 8 as black and I
just resigned here
um to answer the question how I would
follow up with the attack I think I
mishandled the attack at some points
like maybe around here I have a better
move than 94
again I might be asking for too much
ignite of seven of course is crushing
but the way to follow up or what I was
going to do is just Knight f7 take take
and then each seven each seven could be
defended with like this move but then I
would take here
maybe I'm not meeting because he
develops his bishop but I'm up a ton of
material and then at some point I would
play I would play g4 to satisfy Nathan
yes German chess player I am playing
viewers you can challenge me on me chess
um
waitwhat
wait Keith Patrick thank you
five thousand bits
came out of nowhere Thank You Keith
um I'm getting like Sohni notifications
on my phone this is so hard to keep
track of I have eleven pending
challenges okay new game give me a
random number between one and eleven
it's five five count one two three four
okay this guy Rashad Byfleet before good
luck Mashhad play the London system it's
hard to play the London system when
you're black I can play the Scandinavian
it's like the closest thing to the
London I'm going to open up the link
from Jack see because I'm curious
that position hurts my head this King
pawn ending I'm actually I'm giving a
lecture tonight at the st. Louis Chess
Club about uh about pawns I'm thinking
to do something about like King pawn
endings so I might take a closer look at
that and use it in the lecture that
might be a I don't know
Gold is but it might be a good position
to show so I don't usually don't play
the Scandinavian cuz that's John
Bartholomew's job but I assume I can
just develop normally
you can't stick around well feel better
Keith drink some water and enjoy your
vacation sounds like you're enjoying it
so appreciate the bits again
then just to explain why the
Scandinavian is sort of like the London
in this case I'm going to play Bishop g4
but normally a white gets a very similar
set up without a pawn on d5
but the setup is very very similar to
the London
but I don't know the the nuances in move
order in this sort of position
I know at some point blacks should play
c6 you'll just play it right away so the
Queen can draw back and then
then usually if if I can I would like to
put the bishop on d6 and then the Queen
on c7 start with e six
any tips for learning a new opening
without strictly memorizing it yeah
well first of all you want identify like
what opening you'd be interested in
playing can I play h5 here
let's just retreat so once you identify
an opening that you'd like to learn I
think a good step is to just find a
collection of games in that opening
where you can kind of slowly build up
some recurring ideas or pattern
recognition I would recommend either
using a site like chess Gamescom or just
solely chess opening Explorer to find
games of like high level players and see
what structures opening leads to and
like where strong players place their
pieces
like if you look up the Scandinavian
you'll see Sony games we're all locked
players are doing the setup and then
like later on the middle game usually
black goes for one of these pawn breaks
realizing Queen 85 or Queen c7 maybe
wasn't necessary
maybe he wanted to play 94 okay so he
wasted some time at the bishop I'm gonna
continue developing
and I think I'll keep them guessing
which way I want to castle because I
could Castle queenside or kingside I
might end up castling queenside
you
it's those so far I'm staying flexible
especially because he's played h3 it
gives me some long-term potential pawn
break with g4 just uh just to open up
the file it might be hard to stop I'm
gonna start with h6
YouTube's decided to start recommending
my videos I've been yeah I've been
wondering how people have been
discovering my videos but I guess is
just a youtube algorithm which has been
been on my side recently
a rookie one
okay so now my king might want to leave
the center at some point
I'll Castle queenside
this is going to take a long time for a
white to build up a queen-size attack
and it's going to take two moves for me
to start opening up the kingside
Phoenix live asking where I'm going next
well I'm going to the st. Louis chess
club in like a couple hours also I don't
think I've publicly announced this but I
think
um on Saturday there's a the leech s
titled arena actually I know on Saturday
there's a leech s tidal arena and I'm
pretty sure I'll be streaming from the
st. Louis Chess Club twitch account I
can't promise but it's very likely been
twitches things for the sub
and I'll probably like have a stream in
like their studio with someone like
monitoring like the graphics and
whatever so hopefully it's a decent
production okay so he wants to attack he
won't also wants to create a pawn break
but I think my pawn break is quicker
you
or is it bent which is that's a double
meaning the
- cold I'll see you later
and yeah
I think the st. Louis chess club twitch
channel isn't like isn't super active so
that's one of the reasons why I would
stream from their channel to try and try
and build up their Twitter audience okay
before
let's go for this this is going to get
shark
I still like my chances
because I have some threats probably
going to take
I think I'll take with night
when I take with night it opens up
ideas at 5f4
also has ideas of just trading off the
bishop
wait he took okay let's take
how long was my time running there and
see when he made that move
and twitches is just a simple man trying
to twitch that's nice
hmm could it be been Feingold he's a
simple man who tries to twitch
maybe not as simple as the sky
what reading do you have to be to play
in the Chess Club
well the st. Louis chess club accepts
players of all all ratings all levels
they have classes for complete beginners
which I actually taught one last night
that's pretty fun
a 94
attacking the bishop I don't want to
trade off the bishop
I could play this of h2 King h1
five
it's going to get messy
you can't take the bishop because I made
him into
he has a choice between these two moves
I think whatever he does I'll play f5
can you give me ideas with a scotch
canvas scotch gambit for whites I could
try and play it next game
Scotch gambit is not the soundest
opening but certainly a venomous opening
okay I 5 but beauty with f5 is I have
two threats I'm threatening the noise
and threatening to track the bishop with
that for
as pieces are so clustered
like they're all kind of hugging each
other
feel bad for them
I'm pretty sure black is just winning
material here
I was just fantasizing about Bishop G
190g one night eh two mates that's
probably not too realistic because he
can take with the king
okay this is a good sign
yeah it's like you're hugging they're
hugging each other when like a tornado
is just destroying destroying the home
okay Knight g3
Bishop is very awkward both bishops are
awkward
now I have a choice I could take care of
queen take I play this he takes and I
take I win a piece I could also just
take care right away
after take take
also looks attractive
because in that line the bishop is tied
down to f2
I'd be threatening f4 the minions Bishop
g1
you
we're considering Queen sacking that
doesn't make any sense
he takes I play here he takes I take
yeah I'm just up
sir and my king is safe
go for this
I
for
you
and the great thing is when I get my
pawn to g3 it defends the bishop which
is kind of trapped
life is good Lyle's about to are about
to open up a file will open up maybe the
e file will open up
see complexes here hello see complex you
like see complex was wanted like the
first viewer is that ever like watch my
stream like a very old name
with sagging the bishop on g4 earlier a
good aggressive move
sacking the bishop on g4 when
oh the the fishing pole trap with h5
take a look at that I don't think it was
good though because he
the bishop and then play 95 this was way
back when and my queen would not be able
to swing over after 95
hello Dario from Italy
what time is it in Italy gotta be like 7
p.m. 8 p.m.
this is a very unusual type of position
but I love it - my Bishop's are doing
work
sometimes is something you see in
bughouse especially this Bishop Don h2
pawn on g3 a good team
with the bishop trapping this rook
I didn't intend to drop his rook but
since rook is just trapped okay now open
a file
wait lots of things are opening up I
could take on e5 first I could take the
Bishop on you too
start with this
you
there's about three I forgot about
now the bishops pinned
my knight spins I could still take the
rook
you
I just want to win as quickly as
possible I think that might involve just
winning material
throw in Raqqah six
you
Queen Astor retreats
age three
take
rook here life is good main-sequence
good to see you
Samsonite on munch break nice
how late is it in Jupiter I was just in
Jupiter I was in Jupiter Romania it's a
small like resort town next to a town
called Neptune this cool place
and Nathan with the GG emotes let's just
keep trading
I'm not an alien I was just in a unusual
town Romania
you know as night spinned
my knight spins okay
I just want to play Queen f5 and unpin
by the way I still need emote
suggestions I have two new emotes lots
things to all the subs so if again if
anyone has suggestions I'm still in the
process of brainstorming thanks
crotteaus for the follow
yes I do have a favorite place I've
traveled to um actually have two
favorite places Iceland was really nice
and London was really nice
Iceland was a few years ago so London
was my favorite place these more recent
times and that's my favourite opening
London is just a good thing all around
I do need a London emotes
suggestion
okay I'm gonna double up in the pond
could pre-move this
already have a lot of hands-on faces
emotes right naka and the Shanklin and
because part of all of those are
hands-on paces
okay his pawns annoying
what to do
we could do this
which works on the second
if he ever does this I do this
you
you
okay yes he got the satisfaction of
making a queen and now the a classic
weights I made here is to throw in the
check and then move far away and mate is
coming
okay good game how's a nice candy game
maybe John Bartholomew is onto something
ask Andy is a nice opening very simple
to play some was I think someone was
asking about this moment h5 take take
and this would be very nice if my queen
could swing over the following move but
he would have 95 and then white would
just be up a piece
thanks for the follow okay another
challenge
see
random number between 1 and 16
very just fell asleep my phone just died
iPhone just died
pick up
my phone is just I don't know what's
going on
I can't start a game without Syria
you
give me a random number between 1 and 16
9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 the sky catch a Cree
good luck who wanted me to play
something Oh someone want wanted ideas
in the scotch gambit so I can't play the
Scotch gambit against g6 I'll play
Knight c3 play a bit differently this
time I'm gonna play h4 going for the
media attack h4 is a very playable move
because usually black should not allow
h5
most creative and imaginative player at
the moments
good question probably Java or Richard
rapport their openings are are fun to
watch
but
just among like strong players I'm sure
there's more creative players who are a
bit weaker so he plays my left six let's
take on g6
there's a pin he has to take back with
the pawn
now it's a question how do I start
developing
I have the dish appear my bishop belongs
on c4 I'm wondering if I can play it
right away because V takes on e4 at
Queen d5
I think that works
play this
now I'm preventing him from castling if
I can keep his King stuck in the center
actually no he doesn't even want to
Castle kingside because my work is on
h-file but I'm still gonna try and
exploit this king in the center I think
a plan is to play this in this
a fried liver style attack
what should Nathan get for lunch
you'll sound good noodles or sushi or
fruits
or just skip lunch and just keep
watching the stream
Bishop g5
now the fun position for black
because he gave away his dark squared
bishop so he has yura ways of defending
the dark squares
you
I enjoy identify the threat here you
play Queen f3
then he plays a 97
the plan might just be to build up
literally
I would love to get my Knight to d5 that
takes a long time so he plays my t7
immediately
I'm realizing I could play Bishop h6 in
Bishop g7 maybe I should have played
Bishop h6 on the previous move
but let's play Queen f3 look even though
the Knights defended I'm tying him down
I'm essentially preventing Knight b6 and
that means both Knights are stuck
there's one Knights pinned and why
Knight is tied down I don't think we
nice at and helps him
just castle
and because okay well now he wants to
develop the bishop
and then he wants the Castle queenside
fives a move
the ship d5 looks fun
because now the light squares are weak I
want to play Bishop c6
if he plays uh you plays rook ba I play
Bishop c6 I'm threatening to win a piece
is both nights with NB pinned
jacksie is taking notes are you taking
notes on the chat or just my commentary
in this game I don't think the Chad is
something you should be taking notes on
I play one game in the bond cloud just
for it fun in a bullet game maybe but
probably not in a blitz game
okay so he just gave me a ruck
should always be careful taking free
material because sometimes it's not
always free but I'm pretty sure that
rook was very free a tough game
yeah this h4 move gives players some
problems
because the idea of h5 is very often
annoying so I'm almost at the one hour
mark
and I did I actually did a schedule a
stream ahead of time I had scheduled the
stream for two hours so I guess I have
one more hour to go X 159 although good
to see you
just curious how common this is each
four
you
h4 it's down there but it's been played
sometimes any master's games
a few Nigel short would be the one to
play this way II interesting okay
another game
give me a random number between 1 and 16
most recent person to challenge me good
luck
Czar of Zee
he's very provisional only played eight
games so I have to take this slightly
seriously I'm gonna play some qgd Brian
be solid
he's playing some ready Catalan ooh
you
okay
one of my favorite variations never mind
when a for a check this is a new move at
least for me
I think bishop the bishop t7 no it's 97
is the main response Queen takes c4 and
c5
chef c6
I play a different item in place e6 and
then B 5 + n Bishop e7
wait does that hang upon
maybe it's acts upon but the okay second
map one
actually I'm not sure
winn-dixie seven
five take
take take
Jib d7 the queen retreats box down upon
but black has a light squared bishop and
white displayed g3 i would play that
we'll see how grave he is to take the
pond
you
because there's many other lines with
different move orders where the Queen
has to move back and then black develops
and then eventually goes for c5
d3o km play Bishop d7
you
you
now see five camp you play it until this
Bishop is defended or he plays mine f3
so keep preparing I need this pawn to be
defended too
Queen b6 is probably the next move yet
to answer elastic holds question if
Bishop takes c6 in this position I would
have went into this line
uh mr. take c6 Knight takes c6 queen
takes c6 Bishop d7 the queen retreats I
would have rook c8 with tempo Bishop c6
with tempo d4 would be a target I think
there would be enough compensation for
black
but now we have a more positional game
also is a stream lagging
I think the audio sometimes goes out of
sync
I apologize for
not sure how to fix that
and thank you what's your name
that's something for the follow
I think most of the time its inked it's
just sometimes my computer feels
overwhelmed
you
oh is it just usually out-of-sync
beaming on a Mac
is yikes Mac is supposed to be good with
handling like CPU and everything but if
it's fine now then that's good
also good that he's thinking he's
probably not as familiar with this
position and I played the structure
countless countless times where if I get
c5 in and I complete developments blacks
should usually equalize and then the set
up for lack is very very direct
intuitive
um yeah if you want to play me you can
send me a challenge on me chess and Siri
is as picking random numbers I'm Shay
picking random opponents did I eat lunch
I had breakfast like a couple hours ago
lunch will come probably after the
stream
but probably not during the stream
you
you
so currently if you want to play me you
have a 1 in 17 chance because I have a
lot of pending challenges but there's
always that chance
what about super a.m. title super I am
yeah super ayam is just a GM
GM
their hand I guess I super I am could be
like a twenty five hundred I am who just
hasn't gotten the Norns it kind of makes
sense
oh I could close the challenges which
are faster than ten zero
but then they're going to challenge
again
this guy's taking his time Jacob but Lee
I'm sorry I'm not playing blitz
Klein comin else
sky Rashad sorry
supposed to be more instructive I guess
this is a downside though of playing a
longer game is that players can use a
lot of time and then and there's time to
kill
did I drink of water I drink tea out of
tea right now
now I'm out of tea
okay he's preventing c-5 because there's
more pressure on this pawn so I could
play a six
nothing wrong with that I don't think
you
so many questions Mia and John breath
all newer super ions I would not
consider myself as super I am my rating
does not does not even meet the curtain
I am requirements even though my peak
rating Medus
yeah players can be GM level and blitz
for sure because blitz is a different
type of game so yaakov n is probably one
of the strongest blitz players in the
country
Nathan I do remember the game that we
played I've been trying to suppress some
memory but it's hard to forget about and
the video should be released tomorrow if
I'm not mistaken so that should be
interesting
Bishop III what
he wants to play this but I can play 95
like
eighty-five
like eat the pie and attack the bishop
if he takes
we take the seat on
structure will change
is there a name of this structure I'm
playing is black
know what it's called
it's just a response against the saw
like early a g3 and c4
guess it's along the lines of qgd where
I I take on c4 so maybe it's more like
huger a
but
oh I could have played c5 I just didn't
want to deal with this annoying pressure
if I played c5 here he could potentially
leave the tension
and just improve the rooks or something
maybe it was playable though but okay
the structure is going to change
Jack C with the bits in sexy
by jacksie is leaving
time is definitely going to be a factor
in this game just because
a long time I've only used
oh he's very nervous haha
deep breaths
see this Oh No
yeah now people can see that
I think I just killed the sink sorry
about that
d6 probably is the best move
neutralizes bishop develop my bishop
I'm really sorry about the slag I don't
know what to do
I could close discord close discord
you
everything else is closed
hmm I will admit I do get nervous
sometimes when I play against really
strong players online like whenever I
play against Tanaka my pollen starts
sweating and I assume that would be the
case with Carlsen if I ever do play him
apart from those two I don't think we
got too nervous maybe Fabiano that would
be scary
okay so I'm probably going to tell you
on e5 but what do I take with Knights or
the bishop
you
probably the the Knights
disappear
now he has a choice I think the strategy
in a position like this is to
continually make him decide between
options
just burn more time
I wonder if the number of players
challenging me could be slowing down the
whole computer
entirely sure though
you
you
you
I don't think the evaluation is much
different between these two moves but
the position will be a bit different so
he takes with pawn
the bishop here
Sharan f to tie down his rook
if he ever plays III than his Bishop is
kind of stuck
I might consider playing h6g 5 someday
I don't think we chest is a reason that
my computer is breaking I think OBS is a
reason
um but it could be the combination
you
okay.you wants to play b4
good move
you
there's many moves I want to play like I
want a castle I want to play rook c8
maybe for para bishop t4
I'm considering a five here like a five
is actually stopping before before take
take take take take his rookie one in
the end
five
I see
I'm just going to play a simple move
Queen a7 keep all the pressure P plays
before I just retreat I keep the battery
you
oh the match is starting in 1 hour and
40 minutes okay that's good timing
you
well there is increment in this game so
I wonder when he got so Valentine is he
gonna start like just blitzing out or is
he gonna flag
see
as he's been playing a decent game so
far it's just time management it's not
been the best
isn't this a draw because of officer
Clark Kings mm every chess game starts
with opposites of color Kings
so okay Bishop b6
if anything quite could be better here
just with the C file he's gonna is he
gonna flag
he's flagging oh I'm so sorry well he
made that 17 moves that's rough
okay the only thing that can slow down
my PC is if I have a tab open I forgot
to deactivate engine analysis
I have only one tab open this is only
tab I have open oh no I have bored
editor from the previous position but
that should not affect anything
so I guess I have two tabs open the
twitch chat and the V chessboard yeah
sorry it's my opponent for
oh he didn't see the time
okay oh uh let's pick another number I'm
gonna get some chai some iced chai I'll
be right back
if you want to challenge me feel free to
challenge me I'll be back in like just a
few seconds
you
you
okay 25 pending challenges
give me a random number between 1 and 24
oh now it's back to 25 ok 1 2 3 or 5 6
perfect harmony my chai
my tie is vegan people see this again
realize that
yes that's what happens when you shop at
Whole Foods okay um let's play solid
let's play names Oh
nevermind I'll spy a qgd if you play
tonight see three I would have liked to
play in them though
we'll play a semi Slav
anyone in the chat place I'm you Slav
Excise sparks are you here
well this is now going to be more along
the lines of qgd we can see to prevents
Bishop at five
and you remember
if I play g6 first or 96 first
but also just play Bishop e7 let's play
96 looks interesting
doesn't want me to play night before but
I'll go for this maneuver
and there's actually a weird idea in
this sort of position where white once
or black wants to play I'm gonna start
with g6 black wants to play this this
and then Bishop f5 and trade off at
LightSquared Bishop and it's actually a
thematic idea like this whole night
maneuver I've had this in many games
actually I played this within the last
year against a Cobian in some like over
the board rapid tournaments and somehow
I managed to draw
hard for life to stop and it's just
positional maneuver because this is my
worst piece
you
what is he doing Bishop g5 back wait
what slow-motion replay you're here
you're here
yes he wants to play Bishop h6 but I can
play Bishop f5
now he's going for minority attack so I
think the standard move is a six the
slowed him down because he can't play a
four by the way after play like rook e1
and then I can take
and then the idea is to bring the knight
to d6 which is a best square
and maybe even play h6 at some points
you
usually if you have a nylon g6o it's a
good way to deal with the minority
attack then c4 as the whole before could
be exploited
not sure if I want to throw in each six
I do but maybe I just want to play this
and then this and just trade-off the
bishops
hmm so when he plays h3 it's following
me he wants to preserve his bishop
okay with me
94 could be interesting
94 after
tactics but I think 94 is very playable
another common idea in these structure
is that if he takes I take and I defend
he can never take here cuz life working
and now my other night wants to come to
d6 very strategic position so now he
wants to go for the minority attack
I mean b5 might be a good response here
stop him from playing b5 fix a pawn on
b4
ninety-five I have rook c8 an f6 so odd
is this and then f6 but then this is
hanging so maybe this this wait a minute
okay so b5 95 and he's attacking two
things
slow down here maybe I could still play
rook c8 we take sticks
takes iff six
problem is you could play Queen c2
week
maybe I can just play like Knight d6 and
then if he plays b5 I take and play rook
a3
then Enys in trouble yeah let's play 96
I mean this is ideal setup I want with
the Knights and I'm saying flexible man
a child it's like a spice thing stuck in
the throat I'm saying flexible I wanna
maybe play b5 maybe not maybe play f5 80
knots
I'll so potentially put an item c4
I think a major goal here is to play b5
night c4 and then before it's kind of a
long-term weakness and c6 is in so weak
so he plays 95 and now I can play f6
and I think yes for retreats
wait a minute Oh
if I take here here's checks on not
winning a piece
this is so suspicious
I can take care
that's just a trade
so I think it's a critical moment
because I can determine the structure of
the position
leaning towards just taking with the
Knights
treats
take with pawn here here
I guess it's not as kind of stuck you
would have to play this
trade
good for a white though
you
and if this betrayed sb5 but then I can
like take and play see five maybe this
is very playable
looks playable
okay I'll go for that
have to use some intuition
you
you
I do have like some half-open
to work with
I could potentially double up
Thank You pastor Jim for following
now objectively this position is equal
but I think positions like this normally
the better player will win just because
of imbalances
I have a feeling it's easier for a black
like I could even triple up
f2 is all just a long-term targets
the cheer jacksy five bits
and this is a type of position net
should be easier to play with low time
I think this is a no-brainer decision
just taken c5
keep my pawns together baby played b6 at
some points
controlling the a file
you can't challenge with work a one
so I might want to play reggae - very
soon
okay - here is certainly a candidate
move
I don't really want to play rook d8
seems too passive
to
guru thanks for the follow
you
in white has ways to meet this
you
rook d2 will probably have to trade
taketake b6
like this is relatively equal
I don't really want to trade
as I kind of have to
tactics here a c4 I guess
let's say C 4 is a candidate move
the c4 is a passed pawn
c4
you can't play queen d4 I don't think
you can take yeah I would have to play
Queen e2
I could trade
see three weensy to rook c8
b5 is weak I think I'll go for that
you see four looks anti positional on
the surface but a passed pawn is a
passed pawn
there's also a queen F fire like we need
to Queen at five well that leaves
anything
you
any other options if I move the rook
back he plays rugby b1
have to take
and then c3 getting double-edged
diseased plants could be weak but this
I'm relying on this pawn to be more
strong than in this week
how can you use Prime to subscribe there
should be a bun in twitch twitch Prime
something
if Nathan's still around you can answer
I need to which Primus subscriber can
answer
uh rook c8 let's do it this pawn can't
be taken by white I think it has to be
constantly blockaded
considering this
in d5
well then he can just take
work
just going to put my work on a more
active square
and see what he's up to
some point I want to I might want to
improve my King and then go for a queen
trade like I might want to play Queenie
four very soon
what happened to my rating this is rapid
it's hard to gain points and rapid I
think the rapid ratings are are pretty
low I don't just don't play enough rapid
but was it over 2400 maybe it was
um I don't know
some of my other ratings are over 2400
so he's provoking queen f4 for Queen e4
but do I play it I probably have to play
it
King is gonna come in my king will come
in
taketake enough talking a southern king
you to King e6 king d3 or King a d1
maybe have c2 in the final position
probably doesn't work though
and what else to play
I forgot about the smooth
completely forgot
I could win the b5 pond
or can I I can
this is probably going to be a draw
my flag
or I win I mean I I have the only pass
pawn on the board
and it might require me to play risky to
win this or just King h6 to win this
teenage six looks decent but that's
risky because Queen e7 all I got made
this is rated and I don't want to draw
thanks master bond for the follow or for
the sub
um
I think I'm gonna try and win this
it's very risky though
will you please cremate it so he's
trying to win this age five I guess
he offered a draw is running down
perpetual because I have a minute left
you just want to run up and win all his
funds but if I walk there it's made in
one I have to move back
this is kind of sad
you
please play Queenie AIDS
you
oh that was just threefold oh good game
it was an interesting strategical game I
don't know if I could have built up my
advantage with a bigger extent
it felt good around here
but
not sure what I could have done better
one two three thanks for the follow
that may have just been a clean game by
both of us
relatively clean
you
f4 was a good move maybe I should play
g5
five is already weakening
ah
or
I was happy with the opening
you
oh it does show the people see this it
does show the mistakes in that
inaccuracies
I don't think either of us maydenhede
lunders I made two mistakes
rook d2
oh yeah in the endgame I probably
probably played some bad news
Queeny five houses when Queenie five
7oe for
played for a win
you
anyway good game let's do one more one
more game maybe two more we'll see
give me a random number between 1 and 27
it's 2025 well now there's there's 29
people challenging me still gonna be do
number 25 29 28 on you 726 Phoenix live
unikz life should be in the chat phoenix
live isn't the chat played against
another IM while he played the whole
team I was in oh so you played an asylum
okay good luck Phoenix life
is he here he's in the Chad that is he
in the Lilly chess board he is okay
we're going to try a scotch gambit
because someone mentioned this earlier
wait was it Phoenix live who mentioned
it earlier I forget
what's my OVA CPU for Sun and jet I
could check that I guess tivity monitor
CPU
the percentage is 87%
which is probably not a good thing right
you
now in 77 percents
anyway we're playing a scotch gambit I
think the stream is still functional
functioning
and he's thinking which is good
whether to be brave and take the pawn
I'm Anne I am you can see my I am title
right here
I am NOT a GM unfortunately
[Music]
this could be another game where my
opponent is just terrified and takes all
this time we finished the opening well
he plays I have six this is uh this is a
variation this is actually transposing
to the pawns eonni and 94 is not a good
move for one very specific reason is a
white can play Queen e2
and normally block would like to play d5
but with upon me five I could just on
passant and the night would be left
undefended and pinned to the king so
Black's already in trouble here
you
in order to defend the knight he has to
play something like this or this and
then
[Music]
do this or I can just take the night's
for free
so now it's white who's winning material
but up a black might be getting some
compensation just because he can play
Bishop e7 Castle Rick Yates and I have
to watch out or thus alignment
I think Zacks villager for watching
always appreciate you here
and I'll admit I don't know the actual
the Scotch gambits die play The Goring
gambit maybe I did play The Goring
gambit
just the Scotch gambit started as a
scotch and then you gambit but maybe it
does include Bishop c4 oops
gay move
this is a developing move and a
prophylactic move
okay well this is a Goering I guess I
like my lesson
hello to Riemann hypothesis I adopt you
is that why you're calling me to add
what was I gonna say Oh checkmate good
game that's why I played Bishop d3
to prevent him from castling I'm
drinking vegan chai vegan and non-gmo
people can see that from Whole Foods
with almond milk and coconuts
coconut almond milk pretty good
so yeah that was a I guess I was a
Goering gambit
what is a scotch gambit
Wolfgang thanks for the herbal thing
thanks for the 50 bits I am NOT vegan
but I enjoy vegan things a Bishop c4 is
probably the Scotch gambit 9 f6
I thought this is some other opening
and of course so analysis board is gonna
slow everything down
oh maybe it's Bishop c5 as a Scotch
gambit and then c3
if they take we have Queen d5 or Bishop
to gov seven
okay I'll have to look it up at some
point on Wikipedia
do I scream longer sometimes this has
been a long stream this is we're almost
at two hours I think I'll play one more
game
give me a random number between one and
twenty seven nine I don't want to count
I'm just gonna guesstimate this is seems
of just about like nine
okay
I know if that was 9 or not but too bad
another efore game 2 hours is a long
time especially because I vote like a
full workday today I'm I have like two
lectures to prepare some private lessons
but I will be streaming this weekend
I'll be streaming the leech s titled
arena so
you see here maybe he's not here can I
accept someone while having a game going
who else is challenging
I would like to accept
you
I just want to play a new name
over a five plus two game wait what
leave
wait what just happened oh I have two
games going
but I have to
Oh No
well this is weird wait let me copy this
link
then my Simon
oh my gosh
okay I think and it's slowing down the
computer hello Gabriel so I'm going to
play this game
then other game is still open so if he
shows up we can play that too
good luck team Kasim
I guess I broke the rules like I play
the game below ten minutes but that's
okay
you
I might be playing two games at once if
this other guy shows up
do this
to answer the question from MZ I will
read my messages after the stream ends I
do not read private messages on stream
it's just a rule
yeah you can I don't know if Twitter is
the best platform to actually message me
it probably like a discord private
message would be good or an email
through like my contact form usually
like every three days I'll sit down and
like go through messages so it's been
it's been difficult especially lately
because it's like 10 to 15 new messages
per day and some messages take a lot of
energy to respond to
so thanks Nick for sharing all my social
channels you can contact me through my
website it's just I am rosen.com slash
contact and that will send me an email
you
anyway let's talk about this
position I want to try and win quickly
this is a bliss game I've gained space
on the queenside I think what I'm gonna
go for here is kind of a dirty trap of
playing this and this and maybe this not
that this and then eventually this
that's my winning plan we'll see how he
he responds
um Jacob but Lee that's not my email I
don't know where you found that though
um but it's it's deactivated
appreciate that people don't share my
email in the chats cuz sometimes their
spam and that's always annoying
you
so I my plan is still going to be my G
for
and
okay this is going to get messy
let's take
you
Knight g4
this is a yellow tight moment I don't
know if this is sound but Yolo
it probably just loses a pawn and that's
the worse that can happen
I'll get some compensation yeah he takes
with Bishop he's gonna take with Queen
I'll play 95 probably
and then
[Music]
this
just on the kingside
it was a fishing pole attempt he kind of
took the bait but he took the bait and
he's kind of getting away with it
you
Queen g3
so this is a pin
this is playable I might be tempting him
to do this but I mean I just put my
castle Queen Queen side if he does this
all be very happy
as in both files will be open
and again time is a pretty big factor
now this is an actual threat though
always playoff six and then I can play
g5 in honor of Nathan
you
Knight f3 so lots of crushes three
attackers I have
Defenders let's just castle
g5 is coming unless he takes
and it'll come later
but it should come eventually
satay long time no see satay
this is a real SEP a probably is it real
sappy
I haven't seen sapidus since like chess
calm um it stick
now the whole goal is just to open the G
file which actually Bishop g5 prevents
okay I'll put the Bishop on c5 now f2 is
a target I just want to play rook f7
wreck f8 Queen b6
he's being preventive
well I guess now it's time for g5
I just want to play g4
I also just want to flag him
to meet him before flagging him
other opponents show up I'm just gonna
abort this game
I think the my king is very safe
you could try and build up on the D file
but I have bishop c6 this is defended
everything's defended
my queen is attacked
retreats
or advance
well it's got some weird structure let's
play
this
okay with the Queen trade
maybe that was a bad decision
there's some nice poll here I want to
play rook H a than G for again in honor
of Nathan though he's controlling H 1 so
it's not as powerful it could take the
pawn
upon
I want to take the other pawn
you
five
I'm not trying to ignore comments at
least I'm cause ignoring that comments
but sometimes it's just too difficult to
keep up with like the chats because I'm
a slow reader and the chat is just
sometimes too crazy
spicy Italian I don't think I'm missing
lunch in the comments anyway I take a
nice clump of pawns walk up the King
attack the b-pawn
keep walking up the King our pawns equal
i've versus five
they're stronger than his pawns
Oh
I want to put the pawn here
we got weird
it's not that I don't like you guys I
just
I'm a bit busy right now bit preoccupied
uh I think I'll do this trying them in
the pond and then once I win the phone
I'll get rook b2 and keep doing things
wants to trade
I have to calculate
I think it's winning
because the worst thing that can happen
take here here take take is that he
plays g3 in c6h4 take take but my king
is inside the box
we play f4 there
what is that evaluation
antek or can i I could take I could take
take and then D for it and swimming
okay oh this is a good position for my
lecture tonight let me just take a
screen shot let's do this well let's not
pre move King seasick so this expecting
me to
okay so we're going into it hopefully I
didn't miscalculate I don't think I did
I guess I didn't consider this line but
I just assumed
Kings should be good enough
should I be winning
you
you
you
let's not stalemate
nice exercise black to move made into
if you want to try and solve it pause
the video but I'm gonna go ahead and do
it okay
good game those are close finish ordered
some calculation
um so
unsound moves in the opening
also can you just take the night with
upon
I think this is okay for him
I am threatening maids but you could
just play g3
and then I would have to like go crazy
for an attack
Oh Queen a1 is there another made into
when a one is nice or queen c1 I guess
so there are three different mates in
two
I missed a peace win in two moves what
did I miss
I take our three followed by Bishop take
a four but at what points
King looking
take f3
oh that's so simple I did miss that I
miss it I only missed it in one move I
was so captivated by all the tension I
probably should have seen it yeah thanks
for pointing that out
probably not the most high-quality game
that's what happens playing so many
games in a row
okay I'm gonna end it there thanks guys
for playing and for watching and for
subscribing everything that you people
do let's go ahead and read uh red pesca
assuming he's streaming on twitch
sometimes he streams on YouTube see
offline he's online
uh and he's on twitch yes okay so let's
go raid
pashka CH right
yeah and goodbye everyone